Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
where we left off in the conditions and
rules rulings regarding wiping over
a person's footwear. wear
instead of washing the feet for woo.
The author is listing the conditions
that make wiping over a person's
footwear
a
substitute or something that is valid. a
valid substitute in place of washing the
feet for woo.
One of the things that he mentions here
is
so what we mentioned yesterday is that a
person has to put the footwear on the
shoes, the socks, whatever it is person
must put them on after having or with
full woo woo that he made having washed
his feet.
And
the next thing is the time limit. There
is a time limit
and that time limit is
24 hours a day and night
for a resident, three days and three
nights for a traveler. Now this is often
confused. It's not a day and night
from the time you put the footwear on.
That's not when it starts. Nor does that
timer start when a person breaks his
wool.
It starts when a person makes woo and
wipes over them for the first time. I'll
give you an example.
Person wakes up in the morning.
They make woo. They put on the
socks or the shoes, whatever it is.
And they make
they break their wudoo
you know between
and
then when they go to make
they make woo and wipe over their socks.
Now when does the timer start? It starts
at
so the next day at
he would have to take those socks off
and wipe over them. Now
let's say the person Now this is a timer
for what? Is this a timer for the woo or
is this a timer for wiping over the
socks?
wiping.
Pay attention.
I'm going to give you this scenario. He
wakes up. He makes wudoo.
Puts on his socks. He makes fud. He
breaks his wul between and
vul rolls around. He makes woo. Wipes
over his socks.
We have what? 24 hours. So the next day,
the next day comes around
just before say an hour before half an
hour before he makes woo and wipes over
his socks. Still not time yet, right?
Okay. And then starts. Does he have to
make woo again?
No,
he has woo.
Wiping stops at 24 hours, not the woo
itself,
right?
He makes wuboo beforeh. He wipes over
the socks. He has woo until
he had a very conservative diet that
day. Okay?
and he makes
with the same that he did before when he
wiped over his socks.
That woo is correct. It's good.
Now
he
goes to bed. He wakes up for fud. He
makes woo. Now what does he have to do?
Take the socks off and wash the feet. So
the time for wiping
stops
at the first time he wipes over the
footwear to make woo. The first time
let's say that he uses them
for wiping.
That's when the timer starts. And the
timer is only for what? For wiping. It's
not for the woo itself. This isn't like
is very different.
itself
no longer takes the place of wool. Once
a person finds water, once a person has
access to water.
So a person doesn't have water, they
have no abil no way to to obtain water,
they make
they make they make
they find water immediately. minimum is
what
done immediately
right very different between that and
that this doesn't affect a person's woo
it affects wiping over the footwear so
it is one day and night for the resident
person who is a non-traer and it is
three days and their nights with for a
or three nights and their days for a
traveler
yakulu
[Silence]
Muslim
Muslim reports on the authority of Ali
who says
the messenger of Allah sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam has appointed three days
and three nights. Three days and their
nights for the traveler and one day and
one night for the resident.
Exactly what we just discussed.
forch.
[Silence]
in it. He mentions now the place that
the person would wipe over. When you go
to wipe, we've discussed this before.
How to wipe.
he mentions another statement of
which is beyond just the ruling of
wiping over a person's socks. He says if
this religion if the religion was based
on opinion and based on
you know opinion and pure human logic
human logic
then wiping over the footwear would be
on the bottom not on the top and I saw
the messenger of Allah sai wasallam when
he would wipe over his footwear he'd
wipe over the top. Now, what does he
mean by this? Well, what part of the
what part of the foot is most in need
of being cleaned if that were the case
would be the bottom. That's the that's
the part of the foot that sees the most
action. Right? However,
it is not an issue of opinion. This is
an issue that is beyond human logic.
This is supraational.
It is above human rationale.
We This is a purification
that is beyond our physical material
world. We don't know how it works.
There's a mechanics to it. We don't know
what that mechanics is. So we cannot
judge and
give our opinion based on our
experiences. This is something that you
see the messenger do you do. That's it.
He says
and then what is wiping?
Well, the correct opinion because it has
not been identified by the messenger of
Allah sall.ai wasam as having a a
minimum or a maximum.
But wiping is the same as washing
for wudoo and that is what is
washing? Washing is whatever the word
means in the Arabic language which is to
run water over a surface. That is what
washing is in the Arabic language. So
when Allah says wash your faces, that's
what that means. And the same thing with
wiping. What is wiping? Wiping is
whatever is considered wiping in the
Arabic language.
And wiping in the Arabic language is any
action
that
is
properly identified as wiping.
So if I were to wipe outwards, if I were
to wipe one at a time, if I were to wipe
with a finger, if I were to wipe with my
whole hand, all of that is wiping.
Correct? Yes. There is a way that the
prophet did it. Sallallah.aii wasallam.
We mentioned that already. However,
wiping is whatever wiping is in the
Arabic language. This is something that
is referred to the Arabic language
because
all of it is referred to the Arabic
language unless otherwise
stated because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
instilled the meanings of the Quran in
the Arabic language. He says,
and
subhanahua
subh. And
[Silence]
I know.